[Music]
back
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
[Music]
good thursday morning
the moglodites
are so upset that sam harris
is controlled mind controlled by hunter
biden's laptop
we have we have a video clip
of sam harris being manipulated by
hunter biden's laptop
i don't know
i don't know why they didn't see this
coming
that sam harris would say these things
oh they're so upset that sam harris said
donald trump was a huge threat and
anything hunter biden did had nothing to
do with donald trump being a huge threat
to our democracy
like nothing nothing to do with it
and america made the right choice
and they just don't like how he he puts
it they don't like how he talks about
donald trump and hunter biden
it's almost like they're offended by his
speech it's almost like they want him to
be canceled they're even calling him
to be canceled
his career is over that's what they say
i'm going to show you this clip it's
fantastic they are [ __ ] butt hurt
to all get out here
about sam harris
speaking a little bit of truth which sam
harris you know sam harris has got his
issues
the guy just
sometimes he just can't shut the [ __ ] up
and i'm kind of glad he didn't shut the
[ __ ] up on this one because they wanted
to move on in the interview
and then he starts talking about
conspiracy theories
and it really pisses them off oh that
really gets in their crawl about the
conspiracy theory you son of a [ __ ] you
mean there's a conspiracy
you mean there was a conspiracy to make
sure donald trump wasn't president of
course there was the entire country
looked at each other went this is not a
good idea i mean if you count that as a
conspiracy
me in as a theorist
i you know you can't you can't really
negate that
that we all conspired together to get
rid of trump oh my god
of course we did
that that that that's called um
election
that's what that's called we conspired
against you [ __ ] idiots to vote your
dear leader out of office because he was
[ __ ] dangerous
and every day that ticks by we learn
more and more of why he was so goddamn
dangerous and our decision
to conspire to get him out of office was
the right thing to do
jack prostate
what's [ __ ] idiot this guy yeah i
don't know if you know who this is
but he's the guy that you know really
perpetuated the the pizzagate theory
that led an armed and armed lunatic
who was deluded by his conspiracy theory
to go and shoot up
a pizza parlor
because
it had children in a basement that
didn't exist
people were going there with cameras all
kinds of crazy ass [ __ ]
filming children in the pizza parlor
people were going and filming children
in the pizza parlor and posting it on
the internet
and claiming that these children were
the children from the basement are being
taken to the basement which doesn't
exist there is no basement in that
building
and these are the same psychopaths that
are upset that sam harris is like yeah i
don't give a [ __ ] what kind of [ __ ]
you come up with
about hunter biden and his laptop it's
not near as bad as all the nonsense that
is surrounding donald trump and his
family that's the other thing they're
really pissed off about
is sam harris says
the trump university
scandal and fraud is much worse than
anything on hunter biden's laptop oh
they pissed about that [ __ ] pissed
like how can you get pissed about that
hunter biden yes was he doing drugs and
buying hookers sure whatever
that's fine was he taking was he taking
money on boards of companies that he
could be the
he could get on the board and take their
money and get paid to be on the board
sure he was
hell a lot of people in this country
including people listening to this
podcast and i'm sure a lot of you out
there you were able to get on the board
of a company that would pay you hundreds
of thousands millions of dollars to be
on the board
and afford you drugs and hookers you may
take the opportunity
i'm not saying you would or you wouldn't
i'm just saying a human being has
options when they have that option
but sam harris also points out which
gets in their crawl that hunter biden is
not joe biden
they're not the same person
that really [ __ ] pisses him off i
mean it infuriates them
that sam harris points out that hunter
biden and joe biden are not the same
person and hunter biden is not in the
government hunter biden was not running
for president hunter biden is not the
president of the united states
what really is frustrating with all of
this other than you know
this complete nonsense
that they can complete that they keep
perpetuating the absolute projection
that that joe biden's
children being [ __ ]
just absolute dumpster fires
is somehow that's not okay but donald
trump and his dumpster fire children
being part of the government that
perfectly fine perfectly fine frankly as
long as you're taking saudi money
and you're taking blood money from
saudis that you traded for classified
information it seems i don't know then
sure yeah that's so that's a a-okay
everything's fine
when that happens but when it's hookers
and blow
in hotel rooms and you take pictures of
it why did hunter biden take pictures of
this stuff by the way
why do people feel the need to take all
these pictures
i don't know
anyways
i mean hunter biden i'm not i'm not
absolving him of the things he's done
sure
and really honestly the reason why the
laptop isn't probably going to get
investigated fully is because of you
dumb [ __ ]
you stupid bastards and interfering in
the investigation trying to seize his
laptop privately all kinds of [ __ ]
that you dumb [ __ ] tried to do
and tried to stand in the way of the
authorities in the department of justice
now they can't do their job because you
tainted it you stupid bastards
how don't you know this
how don't you understand these things i
mean clearly you don't understand how
justice works you're yelling and
screaming about a [ __ ] legal search
warrant that a federal magistrate
issued a warrant on based on probable
cause
the doj is now subpoenaing the first 15
[ __ ] boxes because there's probably
crime in those boxes
we found out late yesterday that
the department of justice is sending a
subpoena
to the national archives for the first
[ __ ] set of boxes that they took from
trump's home in mar-a-lago
oh this is an injustice this is
unprecedented yeah it is unprecedented
that a [ __ ] former president of the
united states
would harbor classified information
illegally obtain it illegally
and it appears he probably [ __ ]
showed it to people who didn't need to
see it and he may have sold that access
to those documents [ __ ] you
unprecedented in my ass
he's a [ __ ] criminal and he should be
treated one speaking of criminals around
trump allen weisselberg is gonna plead
guilty to crimes in the state of new
york
it seems he's turning on the trump
organization he's cooperating against
them
here i i can't i can't stress enough i
can't stress enough how much how much
this is frustrating the country doesn't
know
that trump's business that he ran for
decades and decades
is under criminal indictment
they are charged with crimes
the same organization that his dumpster
fire kids were helping run while he was
president remember remember the state
fake ass stack of papers
on the [ __ ] folding table
and he had some dumbass [ __ ] wish.com
lawyer come out and talk into a
microphone and say yeah he's gonna hand
over all his business to his children
this is the papers that prove it it's
blank it's all in folders and it's blank
but yes he's going to not do yes do that
that's what i'm supposed to say and he
weighs 135 pounds that is true the [ __ ]
out of here with this [ __ ]
he's a [ __ ] criminal they're charged
with crimes in the state of new york
the business that is supposed to be the
landmark of how great he is in the
business world and how smart he is
this is like if the people who were
[ __ ] criminally indicted for enron
came out and claimed how great of
business people they were
they're frauds their [ __ ] frauds
allen weisselberg is gonna or he already
has i think
has he already pled guilty this morning
to being a [ __ ] idiot
i posted on twitter because i was i was
trying to tweet about alan weiselberg
no i know what it was i was texting our
co-host gabe i said gabe put alan
weiselberg
on the thumbnail
and we're gonna put him in the title
today for the episode
and i kept typing and trying to type in
alan weisselberg but it kept saying why
so [ __ ]
on my on my autocorrect it said why so
[ __ ]
i'm not kidding you go look at it i
didn't make that [ __ ] up i didn't make
gabe you know make some fancy photoshop
thing that's real
and the reason why it's real is because
when alan weiselberg was originally
indicted on criminal charges as the
chief financial officer
donald trump's number two at the trump
organization
when he was indicted i called i said
we shouldn't call him weisselberg we
should call him whistle [ __ ]
because he was he was why so [ __ ] he
was completely [ __ ] here and then
trump organization apparently as [ __ ]
too
i don't know what kind of deal allen
weisselberg has worked out with trump
here
if he's just turning on the turning on
the the trump organization
but uh the trump organization and i've
said it before the trump organization is
gonna fall like a fresh-cut tree
it's it's done with the criminal with
the criminal investigation alan
weisselberg now uh plea pleading guilty
to these charges
and the civil case against
the trump organization at the state of
new york because now
that evidence in the criminal case is
going to be used in the civil case i'm
sure
that alan weisselberg is going to plead
to
trump organization is completely [ __ ]
and what that means is one of his money
laundering machines
gone
and maybe that's the deal that trump has
made with weiselberg yeah sure you can
flip on the company the company will you
know go down
it'll be dissolved but at least at least
i'll have my save america grift he's got
that he's got that money machine which
is causing all kinds of problems
in republican uh
donations and public republicans getting
campaign dollars
which is having effect on these senate
races
but that's a whole nother story
why in the [ __ ]
do these people still think this guy is
a good idea
how in the how in the [ __ ] hell
can you con sit around think about a few
things just a couple things
you don't even have to really go all the
way back to january 6th
just a few just a couple things just
this [ __ ] in new york maybe a couple
things
about the documents in florida in
mar-a-lago
you don't even have to go to the whole
[ __ ]
he tried to commit a coup and commit
treason
on that front
you don't even have to use that
information
to come to conclusion and it's probably
not a good idea to to [ __ ] with this guy
anymore why don't we send this
[ __ ] out to pasture
let him eat big mac to bucket at kfc for
the rest of his life
nope
tie all in yeah baby
let's get indicted too [ __ ] it
let's get indicted too
i want to go down in the history books
i don't know what the hell their
thoughts are i can't figure it out
i wish i could
i mean we tried to
show you what they're saying
because their obvious plan is to have
this guy in charge again so that he can
just pardon everybody get everybody out
of trouble get himself out of trouble
that's the whole key here that's why
they [ __ ] hate liz cheney
that's why they were cheering that she
lost not knowing that she they actually
gave her a national platform to run a
national campaign against them they have
no clue they did that
they have no clue by by forcing their
way into that primary in wyoming having
that crazy psycho win
at clown
that wish.com carrie lake i think she's
i think gabe's right
she is carrie lake's clark kent
she's she's weird it's weird it's funky
it's funky
but they gave her a national platform
and run against him
so now you have tish james
in new york
going to take an axe to the trump
organization
as she's probably going to use the
evidence that alan weisselberg has used
to flip and do a plea deal here
we have
liz cheney losing her race in wyoming
and you know she's gonna she's gonna
[ __ ] take that to the bank she ain't
just gonna let that go and go quietly
into the night [ __ ] that
she's gonna take an axe to the gop
trumpism
you have georgia you now have the the
fbi down in florida
you have you have the department of
justice
in washington dc
because of january 6 this guy is
completely [ __ ] here
completely [ __ ]
jesus christ we watched the video
yesterday mike flynn even admitting yep
donald trump's gonna get indicted
he's gonna get indicted now here's the
thing i believe what they're doing
because steve bannon is freaking out too
freaking the [ __ ] out the reason why
they're freaking the [ __ ] out
is because they know they've reached the
part
of this [ __ ] around saga in the find out
phase
we are now there
for trump
and people close to him
we are very close to seeing what actual
charges that the department of justice
brings where they bring them and what
they bring them for
because my thought was months ago that
what the department of justice would do
is bring one charge one
against trump
just one one they knew they could
[ __ ] dunk
and they would they would aim
and fire at that one charge
and that was it
that is not what it appears to be today
what it appears to be today that they're
gonna pile onto this [ __ ]
because they have more than one that is
a slam dunk
so they're gonna pile as many dunks on
this guy as they can
and they know they'll get one
which is their typical strategy by the
way
their typical strategy or prosecutors
normal strategy is to pile on as much as
they possibly can
that way they can make sure that they
get one charge to stick
but with trump it was going to be very
difficult
because how he distanced himself or it
appeared that he distanced himself
from these charges these crimes
but it's becoming more and more clear
and more and more apparent that he was
not distancing himself again i've said
it the last several weeks if if he
really i call him the cheeto dust
mobster you know that
but everyone claims and compares him to
a mobster
i said if he is a mobster he's the
world's [ __ ] worst mobster the
world's worst
no way no way would an actual mobster
let there be
closed-circuit television that could be
subpoenaed in their home especially the
place where they were committing crimes
not a thing
not a thing and if a mobster did do that
they're not a very [ __ ] good one
what a bunch of dumb [ __ ]
now it may be that he had to have these
cameras in his residence for
the secret service to protect him
but this is of his own doing
you you took the order from putin and
ran for president in 2016 trump this is
of your own doing
you wanted that trump tower in russia so
[ __ ] bad you had to have it you had
to have that you had to add
add that laundering machine
to your collection
because he knew he knew that if he had a
trump tower
in russia that would be the
the golden goose
of money laundering machines
that's that's why he desired it so much
that's why
because he knew it would it would it
would put
tons of money in his pocket he could
pretend to be rich for the rest of his
life if he got a if he got a trump tower
in russia
definitely could do that
he would be part of the russian
oligarchy at that point
but there was just one stipulation it
seemed
because they never could work that deal
he had to you know it seems he had to
really bang up the 2016 election
he accidentally won
and here we are fast forward here we are
he got a little taste of power
couldn't give it up
he couldn't run a government to save his
[ __ ] life
it's it's surprising that we still have
a country
after knowing how this guy handles
documents and [ __ ] how this guy is so
derelict in his duty not just not just
on january 6 every single step of the
[ __ ] way
and yes
we have a lot of making up to do we have
a lot of [ __ ] repair to do in this
country
because he let fascism out of the bag
all these [ __ ] neo-nazis he's america
first
fascist
these ultra magaz
these white christian nationalists
crawled out underneath their [ __ ]
rocks and had permission to be bigots
racist misogynist
and fascist
and they took parts of our government
away from us
our
government it's [ __ ] ours
the federal government's ours the state
governments are ours the local
governments
are ours it's the peoples
and it should represent and look like
the people
and that's the whole point of democracy
that's why they want to tear it down
that's why trump is fighting so hard oh
my god have you i don't know if you've
opened a truce social that's what it's
officially called i call it fraud social
here i don't know if you've opened a
fraud social account
but it's i
the only thing i do the only thing i do
on fraud social is go look at grandpa
poopypants's freakout freakout post
dude was posting charts yesterday
he was posting fake ass charts
i don't know he's got some kind of
[ __ ] polling group that makes up
polls makes up information
that makes it look like trump is cool
just like don jr retweeted that video of
his dad doing the jerk off dance
and he thought his dad was cool
this company apparently does polls just
to make trump look cool
and he was tweeting their graphs
without sharpie i want to point out
there was no sharpies on these graphs
so it is
very likely that these graphs are fake
oh boy
you just can't make this [ __ ] up
dude is tweeting out graphs and charts
about how he's popular i'm not kidding
you
guys got less
followers on his own social media
account
on fraud social then donald trump jr has
on twitter
less than half
i noticed that yesterday
when i was flipping back and forth
trying to give you guys the information
over on fraud social
because i know you don't want to open an
account over there
so i did the good deed of opening an
account
and keeping tabs on grandpa poopypants
over on fraud social a lot of people
like hey stop posting his stuff they
kicked him off twitter
stop posting his stuff well look
look god damn it there are some of those
posts that are garbage
some of the posts are garbage there's no
need to even look at them
but the ones that are significant that
are newsworthy
and i say they're newsworthy because it
gives his mindset
it shows what state of mind this [ __ ]
idiot's in
we need to see that we cannot look away
if you want fascism to take over this
country just cover your [ __ ] eyes and
plug your ears
it won't take very long
for them to take over
they're telling us write out loud what
they want to do they're saying it
they're not hiding it they're saying it
right out loud
steve bannon mike flynn marjorie taylor
green donald trump
they're telling us what what their plan
is
and those graphs are part of their plan
now i don't know if
alan weiselberg pleading guilty and
flipping on the trump organization is
part of the plan here i don't know
if rudy giuliani testifying for six
hours
in front of a georgia grand jury about
election fraud in georgia and election
intimidation in georgia is part of the
plan it doesn't seem like it it doesn't
seem like the fbi
going into mar-a-lago
and uncovering more crime
is part of the plan
it certainly it certainly does not feel
like it's part of trump's plan and
that's the reason why i post it that's
the reason why
the guy the guy is [ __ ] his diapers
and he tells on himself he always has
always has we know that
we know he projects like a [ __ ]
king projection
that's why they're mad about the sam
harris clip that's why they're mad
about the sam harris clip and we're
gonna play it today on the [ __ ] list
roundup thanks for joining us as you do
every single weekday monday through
friday two full hours noon eastern 11
central nine pacific on youtube twitter
and twitch and simulcasting from the
midas touch facebook page this is the
tony michaels podcast i am the tony
michaels please support pro democracy
speech today you can support our show
support.tonymichaelspod.com or use the
qr code in the corner to show your
support
you can show our show support but show
other shows support
this is super important
it's super important for you to engage
in your democracy engage in your ballot
and i'm not just talking about marking
that ballot i'm talking about engaging
doing what you do best you pro-democracy
people do best
which is get out there
kick some names and take some ass
and really do the thing that we should
be doing is democracy engaging
you watch these campaigns fetterman
betto some of these others get involved
get involved in these campaigns even if
you're not in the same states you can
help
you can help
one one way to help is a little bit of
cash these campaigns need money it costs
money to do this stuff
and the republicans are running out of
cash so now's the time to dig deep in
the couch get a few nickels together and
give it to a campaign maybe give it to
several of them we have to fight this
fight we will we will keep the house and
we will raise the amount
of majority that we have in the senate
get a real majority not 48.2
i'm talking about a real [ __ ]
majority
so we can crush up the [ __ ]
filibuster send it packing and do the
thing that we need to do
which is advance democracy in this
country advance rights
codify equality and equity it's enough
of this nonsense this fascist [ __ ]
we do not want the blueprint that ron
desantis is laying out in florida [ __ ]
that [ __ ] get out there and do what you
do best and do democracy don't go
anywhere we will be right back after
these messages
with the [ __ ] list roundup
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
i've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever i try it never
sticks so when babel made a mag edition
i knew i had to give it a try babble
maggot edition makes it really easy to
learn and there's lots of lessons to
choose from like subtly racist to
full-blown white supremacists the first
lesson began with learning simple
phrases and soon i was putting those
words and phrases into a conversation
each lesson takes about 10 to 15 minutes
to complete and they're all really
different which keeps things interesting
the app is really smart it actually
keeps track of the word that i'm
struggling with i chose babble mag
edition because it's created by smart
white people like me and now i can't
wait to explore meet new friends and use
my new maga skills with my in-laws all
lives matter
[Music]
jumping back into it this is the tony
michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome welcome back to
the show
thanks for sticking through the break
[Music]
oh all you new listeners out there love
having you
give you an idea what the tony michaels
podcast is about we go through the
tweety tweets and the trendy trends we
surf them
we go surfing on twitter that's what we
do here at the tony michaels podcast
it's called the [ __ ] list roundup but
before we do that
i want to also give you an idea of what
also happens here every single week at
the tony michaels podcast we run a poll
you get to vote this is democracy god
damn it
and you get to vote here at the tony
michaels podcast go to our twitter page
at tonymichaelspod
follow us there you can vote every
single thursday for the abone end of the
week
the bone of the week poll will be
released today probably this evening you
can also vote on youtube so don't forget
to subscribe and click the bell
notification there you'll be notified
for the poll of the bonehead of the week
every single week here's what happens
you vote you decide who is the bonehead
of the week and every single friday
every [ __ ] one of them
in the second hour because we do twofold
hours every single weekday in the second
hour of the friday show me and gabe
break down your vote
so you decide who is the bonehead of the
week and we break down those boneheads
every single week on friday
in the second hour you can also download
bonehead of the week
every sunday
we cut it out it's such a good segment
we love that segment everyone loves
bonehead of the week
b.o.t.w
everyone loves bonehead of the week
so we cut it out and we put it all on
its own on the directory on sunday we
also do a best of on saturdays so don't
forget to go download on apple spotify
google seven days a week the tony
michaels podcast give us a great review
while you're there on your favorite
directory don't forget to do that
there's a lot of [ __ ] around up we have
a lot of video clip
to get to so
let's
start the countdown surf's up let's go
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome back to the show it's
time to surf the tweety tweets and the
tourney trends and the [ __ ] last round
up and we have a lot of [ __ ] to round up
today uh gabe sanchez should be joining
us soon for the [ __ ] list roundup but
i'm gonna go ahead and start
piss on it let's start let's get into it
let's go to the timeline there's a lot
of stuff going on i want to show you and
here's here's the uh
here's what happened when i tried to
type in lancelberg this morning you see
it why so [ __ ]
that's not that's real that's real i
started typing it in and that's what
popped up
what the [ __ ] now well it happens here
is the here's the clip of uh sam harris
that they're freaking the [ __ ] out about
they're freaking out about sam harris
and i don't know if you guys know who
sam harris is he's a talking head he
comes up with a lot of theories
now he's a very well-known atheist
uh and he he likes to bash religion
and but
he also has a lot of dumb ideas you can
imagine
um
that is a possibility especially when
he's great friends with joe rogan sam
harris is great friends with joe rogan
he's been on the rogan podcast a lot of
times he's also been on the bill real
time with bill maher
over and over and over again so you can
imagine you can imagine some of the
ideas clanking around in this skull
but he is not he is not on the
maga train here he knew the threat that
donald trump was to our country
and because he knew what the threat the
threat that donald trump posed to our
country he understood i don't know truth
and he's dropping a little bit of it
here and it [ __ ] pisses him off
it pisses him off that he's just
saying cold hard facts let's listen i
mean hunter biden at that point hunter
bind literally could have had had
the corpses of children in his basement
wait wait wait so sam heiress here is
claiming
that uh maybe honor biden had corpses in
his basement but
even if that was the case let's hear
what he has to say even if
hunter biden had stacks of dead babies
in his basement what would harren sam
harris think i would not have cared
right it's like it's there's nothing
first of all it's hunter biden right
it's not it's like it's not joe biden oh
that really pisses him off that really
[ __ ] pisses him off
when someone points out the fact that um
hunter biden and joe biden are not the
same person that's not a thing it's not
it's it's not a thing
i mean you want it to be a thing you
would think it's cool for that to be a
thing but that's not a thing and hunter
biden is not hunter biden's laptop
either
they don't have some weird
uh digital relationship that makes them
the same thing
really stupid
but
even if joe like even whatever scope of
joe biden's corruption is like if you if
we could just go down that rabbit hole
endlessly and and
understand that he's getting kickbacks
from hunter biden's deals in ukraine or
wherever else right or china
it is
infinitesimal
compared to the corruption we know trump
is involved in it's like
here you go here you go
sam harris absolutely
absolutely showing
right out here in front of the camera
hey look um which i don't understand why
this is so groundbreaking i mean i guess
because
sam harris to some extent overlaps
um some of these
[ __ ] right wing ultra maga america
first nazis
i guess because of that because there's
some overlap like in the venn diagram of
stupid
uh i guess they're upset
sam used to be a hero
now
now it's being crushed
it's being absolutely crushed
because he's i don't know saying the
obvious thing
like it's not even really that sam
harris is dropping a lot of facts and
truth here
i mean i guess it is truth and facts but
it's just the obvious thing it's obvious
points it's like yeah water's wet
that's what happens
the ground the
the ground gets wet when it rains
like you know just obvious [ __ ]
cars have tires in the around and they
go in circles
i mean this is not
just obvious [ __ ]
it's not hard
to [ __ ] point out this stuff sam
harris isn't saying anything
groundbreaking here
they're not
but
he's saying it to an audience that does
not want him to say it let's continue
it's like it's like a firefly to the sun
right i mean like there's just
it doesn't even it doesn't even stack up
against trump university
and here's here you go he just keeps
like knocking him down
right like he doesn't stop
sam harris could have stopped in his
first statement doesn't matter what
hunter biden did it was
nothing nothing was going to stand in
the way of of america
doing what it did and deciding that hey
the corruption that donald trump is
involved in is not good for our country
that that's pretty easy that's an easy
[ __ ] obvious fact to point out and
again is it really fact or is it just a
[ __ ] it's just something that's
an obvious logical conclusion i mean
yeah it's a fact but jesus christ in
this day and age with where we don't
live in facts just obvious conclusions
should be enough but they're not
but he continues to knock them to punch
at trump punch at trump university here
saying that trump university is much
much more corrupt and and much more
troublesome than anything anything that
hunter biden did
right trump university as a story
is worse than anything that could be in
in hunter biden's laptop in my oh and he
really digs at him he really digs here
by saying that the trump university is
worse
it's worse than anything
anything
that is in hunter biden's laptop
look at these guys faces they're like oh
[ __ ] i can't believe he just said that
my view right
now that's not that doesn't answer the
people who say it's still completely
unfair
to not have looked at the laptop in a
timely way and to have shut down the you
know the new york post's twitter account
like that that's just a conspiracy
that's a left-wing conspiracy to deny
the presidency to donald trump
so here he's saying
because we all have heard this nonsense
in your comments you've had this
nonsense in your threads
that that there's some left-wing
conspiracy to make sure to
to hide hunter biden's laptop so donald
trump wouldn't win that's the big
conspiracy here that that that somehow
somehow the truth didn't come out about
hunter biden because joe biden had to
win
and sam harris picks this apart a little
bit here i think he's wrong here exactly
that that there's some conspiracy to
hide hunter biden's laptop that somehow
some way the american people were all in
this together liberals were all in this
together to make sure to ignore hunter
biden's laptop just the same way
the same way that that the entire right
completely ignore every single piece of
corruption every single piece of
projection every single piece of [ __ ]
grab them by the [ __ ] for crying out
loud they completely ignored all that
[ __ ] act like he was some kind of great
christian or something get the [ __ ] out
of here so i'm i'm not really agreeing
this next part of totally what sam
harris says absolutely it was absolutely
right but i think it was warranted right
and i'm and again it's a coin toss as to
whether or not someone said that
particularly
they're freaked out here by the way
these two hosts are freaked out by what
sam harris just said because basically
what they heard was is that it was a big
grand conspiracy by the left to hide
hunter biden's laptop
that's that's that's what that's what
they just heard and when they hear
something oh my god these [ __ ] right
wingers when they hear something when
they hear something that backs up their
[ __ ] oh man they go [ __ ] go balls
deep on whatever that is oh wait you're
saying there's something that backs up
our nonsense well let's talk about that
listen
really sorry i i was the one that said
we should move on but you've just said
something i really struggled with that
which is
the kids in the basement you no no [ __ ]
the kids in the basement
whoa [ __ ] the what easy easy their
killer
now this is where jack prostate gets
really pissed off
right
i forget i don't know how you say his
real name postiac or poss breck or i
don't know project prostate he's this
[ __ ] guy who perpetuated he claims to
be a journalist he pretends to be a
journalist he perpetuated the [ __ ]
pizzagate thing that there were children
in a basement in a pizza parlor in
washington dc a basement that doesn't
exist by the way
led a lunatic
to get a gun and go there and try to
start shooting people people were going
there with their [ __ ] cameras
to film and take pictures of children in
the pizza parlor who were patrons who
were eating with their families
posting them online claiming that these
children would be holding hostage and
[ __ ] they were eating cheese pizza dummy
they were just eating cheese pizza
that's all they were doing i don't know
maybe pepperoni
i like pepperoni
but sam harris here throws cold water
not just on the hunter biden laptop
[ __ ] but he also throws cold water
on jack
and throws cold water
and mocks the pizzagate
just completely mocks it
because it's [ __ ]
it's [ __ ]
everything these [ __ ] say about
conspiracy theories jesus christ the
whole goddamn trucker convoy
was a bunch of [ __ ]
complete and utter [ __ ] let's
continue i'm interested in democracy
you're saying you are content
with the left-wing conspiracy to prevent
somebody being democratically re-elected
as president well no i i'm conte well so
it's but the thing is it's just not left
wing right so liz cheney is not
left-wing right
so here here he's starting to change a
little bit
about what he's saying gabe have you
seen this video i know i know jack
has blocked you
yeah no i i i can't see anything that he
that he posts because at all no i sent
you this video someone else posted this
video yeah yeah i could i can see that i
can see this video now well obviously on
the show but i can't see when you sent
the original one this morning and right
you quoted i was like
don't that's this person blocked me
that's why i actually embed tweeted the
video because i figured he had a lot of
people blocked he's got like half the
universe blocked because he's such a
[ __ ]
how do you say his last name i say jack
prostate what yeah i know it's it's it's
uh prosthesis prostasis okay yeah
sam harris throws cold water not just
again on the hunter binding laptop thing
like this is all a bunch of [ __ ] he
also mocks jack for the pizzagate thing
yeah but what is it what it what does it
say trigger what
trigger uh
uh
in the bottom left corner let me let me
pull the uh
the banner down here
we'll play it
liz cheney's everything
what i don't know it's kind of boring
t-r-y i know i think it's n-o-m-e-t
no no
no no
no
i don't know is that even a [ __ ] word
i don't know
i don't know i'm bad with words oh i get
it it's like trigonometry oh
trigonometry so what this is
i got it oh they're they're
right wingers just brilliant aren't they
just brilliant
oh man it's you know because what's
funny about this
this is trigonometry trigonometry
because they want to trigger the left
dude they are so [ __ ] pissed this
morning about this clip oh my god they
are freaking the [ __ ] out
that sam harris says this [ __ ] now you
know who sam harris is right
um do i well sam aaron
he he's been on joe rogan
well he's a talking head i wouldn't call
him a philosopher well he's called an
american philosopher well that okay i'm
a philosopher there jesus christ
he's also a neuroscientist yeah okay
that okay right and i'm a rocket
scientist give me a [ __ ] break this
guy okay now sam sam harris might be
smart but he's only smart enough to go
on joe rogan in real time with bill
maher and say a bunch of dumb stupid
[ __ ] yeah right i mean
this guy this guy's intelligence only
gets him to a certain boundary right i
mean should we change our profile bios
to say i'm going to i'm absolutely go i
am no longer the host of this show i am
the philosopher of this show god damn it
and i eat salsa everyone some people i
think god stop with the salsa it's the
salsa it's no she okay ty
told people this morning come watch the
show if not
to hear him say
here in missouri
it is salsa we gabe we don't wash our
clothes here in washington we worship
there's an r in there somewhere yeah
somewhere it's hidden it's deep down
deep down there and and our first
president was george washington
that's his real name there's an r in
there somewhere yeah and i'm showing you
guys
in it too it probably and the closer you
get to st louis people know this
um
toilet has an r in it it's toilet
that doesn't make any sense yeah it's a
toilet which is something we talked
about with brent yes so if anyone wants
to go check out that interview that's
funny we talk we talk a lot about speech
and what you call things and how it how
all that works uh with brent daryun so
you should go
you should go check out that interview
it's in the uh it's in the interview uh
playlist i believe on the youtube
channel so subscribe click like
um and uh find that video
but back to sam harris here yeah yeah
back to sam harris the the philosopher
um that is sam harris
sam harris yeah i i mean i i guess he's
self-proclaimed
um a philosopher
but
he's a talking head
and he says a lot of things they love
right because he's on joe rogan's show
right right he has a lot of libertarians
by the way i had something to bring up
on joe rogan in a moment once we
discussed oh really is this news or
something that you did or it was just
it was news that was covered yesterday
in a recent podcast okay yeah okay good
good yeah well i i would love to bash
joe rogan is that what we're gonna do
actually
you're not gonna you're not oh we're
gonna do the opposite we're gonna agree
with joe rogan this is a weird day
these weeks are getting really [ __ ]
really [ __ ] exhausting i mean every
single day we have to we have to jump up
and down and be excited about all the
trouble that the trump uh organization
that the trump administration
the trump crime family and all his
allies are in i mean it just gets better
and better and better and they're
freaking out more and more and more and
it's getting
it's getting exhausting it's it's almost
like it's getting tough winning like
we're gonna get tired of it we're gonna
get tired of winning i i don't know
someone said that at once boy something
like that but i i think all this winning
is really going to wear us out but now
today you're telling me i get to agree
with sam harris and joe rogan all on the
same day this is crazy okay let's finish
let's finish watching sam harris just
completely melt these two [ __ ] idiots
it was a conspiracy out in the open it
does but it doesn't matter if it was it
doesn't matter what parts conspiracy
what part's out in the open i mean i
think it's like if people get together
and talk and talk about what should we
do about this phenomenon you know if
it's like if there was an asteroid
hurtling toward earth
and and we got in a room together with
all of our friends and had a
conversation about what we could do to
deflect its course right
is that a conspiracy
i mean is it a conspiracy that everyone
in the country collectively went to the
polls and voted against donald trump and
i mean what a conspiracy gabe what a
conspiracy that the majority of the
people in this country and majority of
states
didn't want donald trump to be president
what a [ __ ] what a bombshell
conspiracy
now this is what they're freaking out
about donald trump says that the most
people in history of any presidential
election voted for trump
now that is technically true
to the extent that a rising population
in the u.s voted for trump but he didn't
win because he got the most votes of any
president
[Music]
again again like
like sam harris just
brilliantly pointed out just because
it's a conspiracy out in the open yeah
doesn't mean there's some sort of
nefarious thing
like
it goes back to the movie because he
said asteroid it goes back to the movie
don't look up yeah like you watch that
movie and you're like man some of that
[ __ ] you know like right now you can
relate to but again just because it's a
conspiracy doesn't mean that it's some
kind of nefarious thing it's just
knowledge
just [ __ ] that people know
why why does it have to be some grand
thing they always got to do this
dematria [ __ ] um send me that joe rogan
link we'll go to that first thing i want
to show everyone here's the charts
that um dude was posting this is
hilarious
so gabe i was i was uh i was minding my
own business last night and i decided
you know what it's been a while since i
checked fraud social yeah he's been
freaking out he's been posting a lot of
articles
right
yeah [ __ ] articles but then last
night i went on and he was posting
charts
you know i was doing a little bit of
research on on this on these charts
because i just grabbed him and i'm like
i i i didn't even do any research on the
company i knew right away this is all
[ __ ] right because he's posting it
and it's a graph that he's posting and
i'm like this is [ __ ] hilarious this
guy is now posting charts on his fraud
social to prove why he shouldn't be
indicted on crimes and that's basically
what he's doing here this is not i mean
basically he's threatening he's
threatening the country with fake ass
information and that's the that's the
funniest part about it all is he thinks
this is going to scare us because if you
look here um it says you know the the
question is who's behind the fbi raid
and 77 of his family and people who he
likes
answered
answered trump's political enemies
i mean really honestly do we believe
that anyone was pulled here that well
okay so there's a lot of problems with
the method with the methodology here and
that's this group right it's this group
so this group so like i was
i was at dinner and then you sent me
this and i got out of dinner and then i
was i was actually reading the graph now
what you see here
is you know who do you believe is behind
the fbi raid on president trump's
private home you don't have to take a
stats 101 course to understand how
skewed
the questions and the the question and
the answer is here right so you say
trump's political enemies the impartial
justice system not sure there are no
other options so you're already skewing
it one way
also typically the way that you would
have something you know you would say
do you believe
this like this group or the enemy or
whatever of this raid and then you would
say
um
absolutely sure somewhat sure not sure
neutral right sure
mostly sure definitely sure like you
would have a range that would allow
people to identify this is like all
right here out of the gate the first
response which you also see in the
typical uh
answering format people will answer the
first one on the list because it's the
easiest one to go for
so that's that's
you telling me that we rigged the
bonehead of the week with our top choice
no no no not at all not at all i mean i
totally i totally sometimes people might
do that
but
they're all equal you know okay they're
all equal and valuable you're not
accusing us of anything no no no
we don't have three versions of trump on
the list last week sure
i mean that's that that's as rigged are
not quite as rigged as this poll here
because i want to point something out to
everybody in the question the question
is if you can't see it and and those of
you listening the question of this poll
this first one was who do you believe is
behind the fbi raid on the president
trump's private home the answer is in
the question yeah like the ants and
that's and that is trumpism in a
nutshell right
they run head first into the actual
truth
and then completely ignore it with their
head up their ass because that that is
exactly what is happening with this bowl
they literally are telling the answer
because if you were gonna ask this
question the question would be
who do you believe is behind
the search warrant on president trump's
private home one of them would be the
fbi one of the answers would be fbi
because that's the actual answer right
right that's the actual and it's not
who's behind it it's who executed
right well right i mean you can you can
you can define behind whatever you can
throw the doj in there if you want it as
well right
but the point is is that they put the
answer to the question in the question
right so that way they could make up the
[ __ ] answers and like you said give
you no other [ __ ] option i mean
they're not sure is kind of not an
option but that's like
maybe i don't know if it's the enemies
or if it's the impersonal i'm not really
sure which one it is right and so when
you have that right out of the gate
you're like it's the political enemies
okay all right that's that's a choice
obviously uh and then you're like the
impartial justice system okay well if
you're saying it's impartial that brings
up a bigger problem but then the not
sure like you said is like well i don't
know it could be either one maybe it's a
little bit of both like it's maybe it's
the doj and garland's you know you know
but
here's the thing the group here in the
top right corner of these graphs are
called the uh travel r group okay
now they have their by the way their
logo is kind of [ __ ] but yeah at this
point no totally fine
so
these people
uh this group have been called out
before now the methodology again so the
method for we called out for what i'm
sure they're non-biased right so they
they have they've been called out in
different ways in the 2016 2018 2020 and
the 2021 georgia runoff election right
now with that
uh for those who for those who don't
know uh stats or or how to conduct
proper polling you know especially if
you're trying to create an unbiased a
non-biased question and answer um result
you want to make sure that your
methodology
is one that is following a standard type
of approach you're using tested and true
like true and tested uh uh uh like
protocols
and the ways in which you kind of have
different methods right now you can have
your own unique method but you have to
at least
allow for some explanation of how you do
that right now you could call
proprietary which they do in some of
this but you need to give some context
so right now they say you know they
utilize six different methods live
callers integrated voice response text
messages emails and they have two
proprietary digital methods that they do
not share publicly
now
you can say that
but without giving context
it is the most vague
methodology approach that you have right
now they say they adjust their polls for
social
uh
social
desirability bias effect the
hypothesized tendency of some voters to
calibrate their responses to polls
towards what they believe the survey
taker would like to hear
okay so that's assuming like oh you
asked me a question i'm like uh i think
you want me to answer this way so they
say they adjust their pulls that which
which i don't believe they do
and beyond that because they lack their
the transparency about its methods
in uh in 2020 the ceo was like i think
we've developed something that's very
different from other people do and i'm
not really interested in telling people
what we do just judge us on whether we
get it right now keep that last part in
mind great because they're always right
we're always right exactly in the 2016
questions in the methodology is always
right in the questions exactly
and
in 2016 during the presidential election
the only place that they got right was
pennsylvania
and because of that they were like oh we
were right we were right right and the
midterm elections in 2018
they said that brian kemp their final
poll was gonna lead
by 12 points
he only won by less than two points
right keep that in mind not even within
a margin of error yeah yeah that's
that's a huge that's like three three
well depending on what your standard
deviation is but like that's a wide
wide
right a margin a margin and a poll of
error is usually anywhere between two
and five percent right right yeah i mean
depending on the poll in the end right
right but i mean
exactly depending on how like
statistically significant you are
on your polling then like your margin
changes and go smaller but if it's a you
know a less like oh i'm only like 50
statistically significant then your
margin mirror might be larger but but
but typically it's not getting your
margin well if you're running a real
poll you don't want your margin of error
to go over five percent right right then
yeah
exactly exactly right if you swing it
like you swing one way then you're like
whoa this could totally be the opposite
result that's why that's why the news
agencies when they show you a poll they
show you that margin of error yeah
because that gives you an indication
whether this poll is a bunch of [ __ ]
trash or not right and the reason and
the reason that people like nate silver
became so popular is because he was
running regressions on top of
regressions on top of regressions on top
of regressions now typically other
polling places like abc nbc cbs these
places would run their polls and they
had their own way of doing it and the
reason that he got so accurate
especially in the 2012 election i think
it was were twenty two twenty yeah
twenty eight and twenty eight and twelve
he was like on the money on almost every
one of them is because he was taking
everything into account and then running
regressions on all of these and getting
down to a very getting his own number
right yeah exactly well and and that's
that's that's the thing about the polls
and the point we were trying to make the
other day right because this group
actually claims um some of the stuff we
were talking about the other day that
some of the ways that they actually do
polls is antiquated right and this group
uses that that fact in their advantage
and they they're like oh well we we
actually we don't just make phone calls
and we do we do all these things these
new ways but the problem is even if
which is probably all [ __ ] if
they're if they're coming up with polls
like this they're probably really
failing when on the delivery of it
because their methodology is absolute
[ __ ] here's the next question
but the problem with
the um that
with the fact is it doesn't matter your
delivery system if these questions are
[ __ ] and the methodology is [ __ ] and
you're always going to be right no
matter what because this this question
here
is [ __ ] so loaded like
this tells you not this question tells
you absolutely nothing no matter who
[ __ ] answers it it says here's the
question does the f does the fbi raid
number one which is already loaded yeah
on president trump
increase your motivation to vote in the
2022 election it actually motivates me
more to know that they went and got his
[ __ ] like i'm pumped up about it i'm
ready to go vote against these
[ __ ] i don't know about you so
i would answer yes on this but there's
no there's no
yes in the favor of trump yes against
trump right there's no exactly so that's
that is
yeah that is a big problem here it might
motivate you but motivate you in which
way right right like oh yeah this is i i
it motivates me
to vote in an election that doesn't have
anything to do with trump right because
the question should be how does the fbi
search warrant that was
exactly what's issued for president
trump's mar-a-lago home
increase your motivation
does it but even even so it would you
know a question would then be like does
the raid right does the search of his
home motivate you to vote right more
like more or less likely to vote for the
those options republicans exactly more
likely less likely or you would have a
range because you're actually getting to
it to an idea there right this yes no
question and then the not i love how six
percent not sure i don't know
what like you're like i don't i don't
understand that i'm not different it's
yeah it's a it's interesting
it's a cop-out for sure but like a
question like this again is loaded and
the other thing is that there was a
lawsuit between the founder
of this polling group and it was a
cali and larosa it was a lawsuit in 2013
challenged in south carolina's law
prohibiting most uses of unsolicited
consumer and political calls made by
adad devices or sorry adad which is uh
automatic dialing in announcing devices
which are robo calls
and basically the founder of this group
was arrested by the state law
enforcement division being charged for
making illegal robocalls to six state
house districts
and they were asking a question of
whether u.s speaker nancy pelosi should
be invited to campaign with six
democrats for the south carolina
legislator
uh and so that
just know that this group already has a
tainted past of it in 2013 the founder
no
are you saying are you saying are you
saying that trump is posting charts from
from a crooked organization surely not i
don't know
maybe maybe they should rename the group
to like crooked polls you know right
well i mean you know maybe maybe uh
the the trump media group should buy
them look
this is
when i saw him posting charts i was like
oh my god this is gold this is hilarious
yeah this is hilarious because there's
no way trump would ever
like
just post because he was just posting
the chart he wasn't giving any
commentary on it because he couldn't
really because he probably didn't know
even really what what it means like they
couldn't even he couldn't even use his
brain long enough to go well this is all
a [ __ ] question i guess it's a
[ __ ] question which i mean they're
coming up with a bunch of [ __ ] right
here's the here's the latest defense on
fox news on hannity's show of why donald
trump did not commit crimes this is
[ __ ]
batshit crazy gabe they they invoked the
clintons here in sang of course of
course thank you course
why wouldn't they let's let's listen
yeah listen uh there is a court ruling
from a decade ago this year uh that is
going to have significant impact on the
legal uh battles that are going to ensue
over this raid and that and no it won't
no no it won't no it won't no it won't
and you're going to find out really soon
because he's going to tell you again
this is the head-up ass syndrome that
i'm talking about like the aniocranial
dysfunction that these people have where
they're asking the question with the
[ __ ] answer in it and they still
can't come up with the [ __ ] truth if
it saved their [ __ ] life here it is i
never thought when you woke up this
morning we'd be talking about bill
clinton's soccer melania's closet
melania trump's closet and donald
trump's raid but that's what this ties
together in 2012
no it doesn't
no it no it doesn't
now here's the thing i said this the
other day on the show i believe the
reason why he was freaking about uh out
about melania's closet is because he was
hiding [ __ ] in there yeah that that that
you you bring those things up right like
the guy could care less about his wives
okay you look at his past he doesn't
wait wait he has more than one wife he's
a christian gabe he would not yeah well
you know
i'm just saying the considering
considering the fact that he was like
where will i where will i bury my
ex-wife uh yeah to put her over in the
the ditch over there like like yeah like
a few hundred yards away from the hole
you know right and well you know he did
have a mow around it a little bit i mean
yeah i mean sure that's mow the ground i
guess a little the silver line in his
lip or something
yeah i mean you probably hired the same
kid who mowed the the white house lawn
you know that he was yelling probably
probably but but the point is is that he
obviously was hiding crime in her closet
otherwise he wouldn't have brought it up
yeah and and and everyone knows that
like it's not again these are
it's like oh that's a fact and that's
the truth that's the an obvious
conclusion here just don't bring it up
unless you're subtly or
subconsciously admitting to your own
paranoia right which is like why would
you be paranoid about someone else's
closet right who the [ __ ] cares also the
fbi isn't in the [ __ ] fold and dry
business or the wash and fold business
there why would they be why why would
they be in her closet looking for [ __ ]
right if they didn't see someone putting
it there on the closed circuit
television unless
unless
he was caught in a lie again and they
never even went through a closet that's
the other possibility they never went to
the closet and then he was like hey
what about my passports and they're like
yeah well we took them but we gave them
back and he was like what about the the
closet and they're like look the body
cam footage nobody even went near those
closets right right well i mean that
could be a possibility but most likely
he is he is paranoid about him hiding
something and they took something right
well and and this this schlub here is
bringing up the fact that
melania's closet gabe is the exact same
melania's cause closet that has crime in
it
is the exact same idea of bill clinton
having a a personal interview that he
did in his sock drawer they lit he
literally is going to try to make this
connection watch this a court rule that
uh records audio tapes and bill clinton
had put in his sock drawer at the white
house of hours of conversation with a
famous historian about contemporaneous
events in the presidency
oh my god so what you know what this is
do you know what this is while bill
clinton was in the office
they actually they hired a historian
to to talk to him about and and they i
think they were planning on doing a book
and that's where these t in these tapes
they
and and they may
should be part of the presidential
record but bill clinton did not think
these tapes did now bill clinton
was not committing crimes on these tapes
yeah right
these these tapes did not relate to
classified material either
so so this guy's saying again
this is the anal cranial syndrome
the dysfunction the head up ass syndrome
is that they run straight directly into
the truth and still cannot come out
oh yeah anything that looks like
coherent [ __ ] thought
they run through come back around for
another lap and go back through and come
back and they're like guys what do you
you know this means like you literally
just you hit it again and again and
watch him hit it again because he does
it again or personal records and that
there was no legal
um
medium by which an outside person
watching challenge that basically what
the court ruled judge amy
berman jackson ruled that the
president's uh decision of what
constitutes a personal versus a
government record is solely solely in
the discretion of the uh president
himself now this is very important this
decision
and if you look the word the word is so
important during
during is so important the thing that
donald trump and this bonehead and
everyone else does not realize and cash
patel has no clue he he like thought
donald trump could stand over a table
and be like
declassify everything even the
mcdonald's rappers and like somehow some
way that when i when i imagine
it's like him attempting to be like
obi-wan kenobi or a jedi and being like
these are not the documents you want
right and he's like these are not
classified documents these are not the
documents you are looking for what what
also that they're failing to realize
here
and i don't know if they need to read
more or
again pluck their head out of their ass
yeah
more but when a president during his
term or her term uses their sole
discretion of what is personal what is
not they actually have to go through the
procedure yeah they have to do the thing
that makes the discretion
they can't just be like oh yeah it's
mine that's not that's not a thing
that's not a thing that's not a thing
wait you're telling me that's not a
thing no there's actual procedure one
four
four these documents these records oh
man and and the sole discretion that is
that is exercised by the president
whoever is holding the office this is
really this is really [ __ ] dumb
because it says right here in this
statement under the
um established by the pra
it's really [ __ ] dumb you have to
follow the procedure donald trump filed
no procedure that's why they went down
to mar-a-lago and got this [ __ ]
if he would have fouled procedure for
this stuff they would not have went and
got this stuff it would be legally in
his custody it was illegally in his
custody um just a bunch of [ __ ]
boneheads just you can't it's oh my god
it's so ridiculous yeah well i mean they
will project as much as they want right
i mean you got to remember last week you
know trump was like 33 million documents
were taken from you know the obama white
house to chicago
and then you know he's making these
claims about not knowing the art guy's
headquarters
and the national archives like hey uh so
let's go through your timeline real
quick and then they're like here's what
happened in january in february and
march and also this claim that you're
making about this [ __ ] about obama
taking 33 million documents one they
were not classified and two any
classified documents are definitely
under our purview and watch right now
right well um
speaking of trump being in trouble
do you think it's i mean we see alex
jones here on the screen and we watched
the last few weeks as he get you know
totally torched in court i don't think
they they slapped him with high enough
uh financial
um no no no problems well remember he's
got he's got other cases coming out
right too so he's got one in connecticut
and one in in texas he got banged up for
i don't know it's about four million
bucks is that about what he had to pay
uh no it was uh with the fines i think
it was like 5.6 so it's 5.6 but that's
with the fines that's because that's
what the finance because
alex jones was unwilling to cooperate
for so long that they accumulated these
fines on top of right now and the the
court fined him the quarterback the
family doesn't get that the court gets
it because he was in and not in
cooperation
no no no i think i think they get yeah
because of how
of how uncooperative he was so they get
almost 6 million bucks here yeah which
is kind of a drop in the bucket for this
guy after we saw what his revenue was
in the evidence yeah but here is alex
jones this is delicious gabe it's
delicious again i said the other day
watching [ __ ] sandwiches eating [ __ ]
sandwiches is fantastic to me it makes
oh it makes me want to dip it in salsa
to be quite honest no no um
no i want hey i want to dip carrots and
salsa that's uh uh
yeah that's a coup d'etre yeah for sure
but here is alex jones uh turning on
trump again he's done this several times
where he turns on trump and he's back on
trump they'll turn on trump well
right but everyone thinks this is
significant i actually don't think it's
that significant but it's hilarious
nonetheless let's watch this is what
trump should be like and i've been
hammering this point
and he's doing it now
and
we have someone i want to say real quick
and i'm going to replay this just just
watching this we need to set our studio
up like this i need to get the mic in
front of me i can talk like this i wish
i had a background with a bunch of
screens on it we could we could really
make something of this show
if i you know a lot of people had said
that i sound like alex jones i don't
think i sound like alex jones i can
sound like him yeah yeah it's a choice
it's a choice right the demons will come
for you if you do not vote in this
election the republican demons will come
to your door and they will take your
children and they will take them to the
depths of hell
the demons now
back to the news i'm just saying i could
do the whole alex jones thing
yeah but how quickly how quickly would
you turn off people from watching us i
don't know i he gets a lot of people
watching he does he gets a lot of people
but those people are crazy oh
see i've been accused of being alex
jones like as some people like oh he's
just the alex jones of the left or some
[ __ ] i'm like no i don't really i don't
do the whole demons and you know they're
they're gonna come you know i could i
could you know look i'm i'm not a i'm
not a lizard gambling or a betting man
but i could probably safely assume that
if we were to put a pole out right now
yeah that would say like uh you know
something from the uh the the the tel
fargar group which is yeah
so we would rig it yeah i mean i mean
here i wouldn't need to rig it to show
that everyone doesn't want to hear you
do that alex jones okay put it out two
hours if you got if you got a minute
while i'm playing this put that out and
see if they'll vote
all right i'm good okay i'm good with
that hell i'll i'll play i'll play ball
with that because of people if people
really want me to talk like alex jones
and be alex jones i may just play that
character
i'm just kidding i really i really don't
want poll's going out
no no good you can do the poll yeah do
the bull let's see what people think but
here's here's alex jones
um pulling out a trump and going balls
deep into desantis here this is what
trump should be like and i've been
hammering this point
and he's doing it now
and
we have someone that is better than
trump
way better than trump this is what trump
and that's ron desantis that's who he's
talking about here yeah ron desantis is
way better than trump is is what alex
jones has concluded
we have someone way better than trump
way better
i think the reason why alex jones is
saying this is because
desantis knows
that you shouldn't
openly commit crime you shouldn't openly
show your corruption you should do that
quiet part
quietly
but desantis knows that the fascism
is what the [ __ ] freaks want
and they bought into this q anon
america first nazi [ __ ]
and that is what descent that's why
desantis to alex jones is way better
than trump yeah because trump is a
performer desantis baby he's an operator
and that's the difference so what's the
pull here should i bring it up did you
get it going there yep okay let's let's
bring this pull up let's see how you
rigged this question now everyone go to
tony michael's podcast um let's see
there you go
um
let's see here oh i like the uh the
emoji here
should tony michaels do the do an entire
episode with an alex jones voice
absolutely i'm voting yes look at that a
hundred percent wow looks like
i'm the only i'm the only one that's
voted
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] i'm the only one
that's voted
now i gotta retweet this damn thing
and then i gotta give it credit you read
it oh see the no's are coming in the
nose are coming in coming in they're
coming in no one wants me to do this um
so you don't want me to do the entire
episode maybe just a segment or
something
right maybe we should do like a demon
blood sucking segment well if you i mean
here look if you really want to do it
the question is phrased such that it's
an entire episode right so anything less
than an entire episode like you could do
an hour and 58 minutes and then at the
end be like and now this is closing
statements this is tony michaels so you
could totally do that if you really
wanted maybe maybe maybe we'll consider
it not you could say it's not
um
uh alex jones for a bit but not for a
long period of time yeah a lot of people
in the comments are saying nope nope
nope not a thing no not a thing not a
thing well i i'm just pointing out that
people have accused me yeah of being
alex jones and i'm not i mean i'm not i
mean i may you know have some tendencies
because i get [ __ ] pissed off and i
yell and scream into the microphone that
may be one tendency but i'm not talking
about lizard people and chemtrails and
trying to sell you [ __ ] supplements
yeah that's not what maybe we should i
don't know it seems like a profitable
business if you guys if you guys want
placebo uh supplements and we package
them up and talk about how it's going to
make you feel good and did you make you
think right did you know that alex jones
sells toothpaste
that's what
it says infowars on it wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait are you telling me
that alex jones
sells like a chemtrail toothpaste is
this stuff supposed to wash out the
chemtrail well you know he's got this
theory about the fluoride right it's
supposed to it's
makes you it brainwashes you or some
[ __ ] that's why they put the fluoride in
the water
you know it's not it's not yet right in
the water so it's not to help your teeth
or anything no i don't know that's it's
definitely in the brain if if you go to
the store there
does it say it has fluoride in it
no it's fluoride free flow well it has
super super blue
fluoride free toothpaste
take a screen cap and put that in there
let's look at this [ __ ] i want to see
this
i want to see this goddamn thing
all right so so it's so it's it's
infowars alex does have like his face on
or is he holding it like hey no he's not
holding it but it's uh you go to the
like i guess but they pimp this stuff on
their show right like yeah
you pimped it out yeah would you guys
would you guys buy pro democracy
toothpaste because [ __ ] we'll we'll make
we'll make some democracy toothpaste if
you guys and it will have it will have
extra fluoride in it
for you who want to be brainwashed by
by the jewish space lasers and the cabal
and maybe even maybe even that we could
me gabe we can make the flavor
we can make the flavor what's the thing
that they say is in the in the kids
blood what's the um oh uh hydro uh
uh oh my god we're supposed to know this
we're i know we talked about it in the
last antifa meeting damn it um the hell
is it
i don't know it's some some something
hydrochrome adrenochrome adrenochrome
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's all right
i clearly haven't had enough for today
so i'm i'm kind of low sorrow seems
essential didn't put it didn't put any
in your uh soda streamer today
the adrena chrome flavor we could do
that i'm telling you i think people
would totally go for that i think
it's possible people would pay for it
you know uh
let me uh
this is here we go it looks like it
sounds like a commercial we could
actually do right this is the super blue
fluoride free toothpaste for anyone who
is listening
for blue they named it super blue it's
super blue man
for anyone listening you will want to
come over to the video on youtube and uh
check out what we're looking at right
now look at the deal limited supply only
25 000 available
[Music]
it's totally limited a revolutionary
toothpaste blend with iodine and tea
tree oil i've never put
tea tree oil like tea tree oil is not
something i would say put in my mouth
it's typically like uh for external
purposes
i've never used it for intern like
people are like oh i put tea tree oil in
my shampoo or conditioner you know or
something like that but i've never heard
of you ingesting tea tree oil but what
surprises me the most here is that this
is an opt-in add to cart instead of an
opt-out right like you think you'd go to
this website like everything's in the
cart right oh yeah everything's in that
cart you gotta opt out of [ __ ] yeah like
you gotta take [ __ ] out of the car to
check out you know just just to do this
this product is only intended to use in
cleaning or whitening the appearance of
teeth it is not for therapeutic use and
does not cure treat prevent or medicate
any disease
now i don't know if at one point they
put this up there and it was like yep
we can cure it all and then they got a
lawsuit wait can you pull it back up
sorry there's another line in there
it says uh okay super blue fluoride free
tree uh toothpaste by infowars life
trademark the groundbreaking toothpaste
that features natural oils and
ingredients used since aboriginal and
biblical times to supercharged good oral
oral health and minty fresh breath and
then there's an asterisk and let me see
what it actually says on the website
though we totally we totally got to do a
spoof commercial of
of infowars life blues
super blue fluoride free toothpaste oh
yeah no the statement is uh these it
goes the asterisk is for these
statements have not been evaluated by
the fda the product's not intended to
diagnose tree cure prevent any disease
if you're pregnant nursing taking
medication or having a medical condition
consult your physician before using this
product hey hey hey a good idea don't
get it yeah listen so this is it because
it's probably it's probably just like
it's not even it's not even going to do
anything to your teeth it's probably not
even really do anything i mean it could
make your teeth worse well that probably
is a possibility and they also sell an
ultimate toothpaste combo i'm sorry one
off of this tangent here but
activate they got the activated charcoal
thing you know which that was a big
trend for if you remember from the trial
when he was on the stand like when when
they were asking him about all these
supplements and they were saying are
these fda approved they're the best
supplements ever and we have the best
suppliers and these suppliers and and
the judge is like okay enough of the
commercial yeah this is not a she's like
mr jones this is not a commercial this
is not an answer just answer the
question he's asking the question you do
not have to do a commercial
like he is so geared in and so in tune
yeah it is pimping this stuff on his
shield
i think i think i think we should do a
spoof of the the the fluoride free
toothpaste we should definitely do we
need a new commercial anyways i know i
have well here i have a i have one new
commercial right
which is a dating
which oh a dating
one oh yeah well you know kaylee
mcinning's sister i know
but this one this one is uh there are
two two that are coming well one that's
done and another one that's i'm working
on which is one that is based on kaylee
mcinerney's sister's act oh okay good
and the other one is just a
just a normal kind of dating service
video
uh advertisement so if you see any you
know eligible bachelors on there you can
call them and
and give them a ring and go on a date
with them you know oh man well let's
let's let's put it on the list gabe
let's try to get them they all want the
no no doubt me the doubt me shirts
they're begging for them i know we've
got to get these done folks i've been
trying to nail him to the ground here
he's got so many projects going on uh
because i know there's a new uh what was
that coming as well that you're writing
that you're working on the the fbi on
boxing uncovering where you found that
video yeah
should we play should we we didn't play
that yesterday let's we should play that
today okay well what first off i want to
go back to um some more
crybabies here
yeah speaking of uh hucksters speaking
of grifters here is um the
uh the wall grifter steve bannon and
listen to how he's freaking out let's
listen pence you're a disgusting coward
just even the sight of you bugs me okay
that's enough i i can't a guy who looks
like that who says he's disgusted at
looking at someone give me a break i
don't know the walking scab the the fact
that
he's willing to comment on someone
else's
situation
well when he is this
i can't tell if the scab has taken over
like this is like a fly moment right
where he has transformed he is like
slowly transforming into a human scab
like he tried to teleport somewhere and
then just oh there was a scab and there
was him and they just kind of mixed
together and the dna is all [ __ ] up
and now we slowly turn into one big
giant slob of a scab you know well it is
kind of gross
um
let's let's go to this video of the
unboxing
of the fbi i heard there might be other
ones i don't know well it looks it looks
like this is a series of videos yeah you
said the fbi has released their unboxing
video of evidence taken from trump's
mar-a-lago home i don't know if there's
grass that that back this up or not
but here is the the unboxing video that
was released let's watch hi everyone
it's your favorite fbi agent
badge number
and today i'll be doing an unboxing
video of box a33 this is one of the
boxes we took from trump's mar-a-lago
home now let's unpack our first item
looks like we have some packaging filler
here you know some basic paper
um actually never mind these are
shredded documents here we have what
seems to be an industrial-sized bottle
of adderall now most of this seems to be
written in russian
and i don't speak russian so i don't
know what it means but i can say i'm
pretty sure this is illegal to have the
next item are photos of melania trump
with french president emmanuel macron
this comes with a letter from donald
trump to tony ornato dated on
valentine's day oh wow um
this has a lot of swear words in it all
right this is a top secret folder that
has not written on it let's take a look
inside
wait is that
yep that is definitely ketchup and here
we have a dvd that's titled from russia
with love starring donald j trump and he
seems to be
soaked in some sort of yellow liquid
weird
oh god these are the tips make sure to
give this video a like and smash that
subscribe button
obviously the fbi has a youtube channel
yeah they do they're posting this on so
you didn't have to you didn't have to go
very far to find this like no not at all
i i think i think his user name is like
fbi and boxers
somebody said we watched a few days ago
true however is a different version that
we it is yeah we we we didn't watch the
finished version yeah yeah um we watched
the the draft version that the fbi
released in the deep dark web and then
they released this version out on
youtube there's also i i hear whispers
from within the doj
that dark garland
is going to release
uh some footage from inside the actual
search that happened so expect that
maybe tomorrow i don't know we'll see
oh so we're going to get footage inside
so we're going to see some of this um
uh closed
closed circuit television is that what
you're saying or is this is this is like
a
no it seems like this is going to be
inside like a like an interaction
between multiple parties uh from the fbi
after like while they were
um
uh actually searching i see i see well
um
speaking of trump and being in trouble
um we're gonna have more january 6
select hearings here soon but this
morning randy rainbow you know randy
rainbow everyone loves randy's videos
randy put out a new video this morning
and i haven't watched the full thing yet
but i totally want to watch it so here
it is and on the tony michaels podcast
randy rainbow's newest release let's
watch it okay everyone welcome back to
the january 6th hearings which will
finally determine the criminal
culpability of former fake president
donald jessica trump
now let's go to some behind-the-scenes
dvd extras from his pre-recorded address
to the nation on january 7th
okay whenever you're ready sweetie and
we are rolling everyone please clear the
set we're rolling thank you okay mr
president you're on in five you got this
[ __ ]
i would like to begin by addressing the
heinous attack yesterday sing out louise
but this election is now over
congress has certified the results i
don't want to say the election job i
just want to say just say you're a big
fat loser my only goal was to ensure the
integrity of the vote
i would like to begin by addressing the
heinous attack yesterday
yesterday's a hard word for me
[Music]
yesterday
such a complicated word to say
when his dentures start to slip away
he's not okay
with yesterday
plain to see
how he screwed with her democracy
pinching big macs while we watch tv
this just stain on
our history
when
the
lords came through they were blue
instead of
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
does it really take the fbi
to verify
he tends
i'm joined now by the man everyone's
talking about attorney general garland
judy seditious conspiracy espionage
bad hair
what the hell is it gonna take to nail
this guy no pressure the justice
department has been doing the most
wide-ranging investigation in its
history well step on it's this because
he's getting ready to announce and we
cannot let him be president again
i'm running out of show tunes the
justice department has from the
beginning been moving urgently to bring
to justice everybody who's criminally
responsible for interfering with the
peaceful transfer of power
[Music]
[Music]
for national security
yesterday
please don't take us back to yesterday
doj and prosecute like yesterday
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
please
we will have the evidence step on it
oh randy rainbow randy rainbow thank you
so very much
for your art
and your time
and everything that you do okay everyone
welcome back for the internet mm-hmm i
appreciate what you do for us on the
internet uh i've also got that the joe
rogan video by the way oh dear yeah
let's let's get that link let's get that
link you know what it's in the it's i
uploaded it
oh yeah because i uploaded the because
it was the post millennial and some
other people and i just wanted the part
that mattered
oh so you cut out the part that mattered
here yeah yeah so here i'm putting up
there
all right so this is joe rogan with uh
babylon b
founder
and the topic that they are discussing
is abortion now the bap everyone tell
everyone what the babylon b is because
trump used to retweet this thing right
right he was on twitter yes and i think
he still posts their articles over on
fraud social yeah yeah so it's just it's
a conservative christian
uh news satire website that publishes
satirical politicals yeah
and it talks about religion and politics
and current events and blah blah blah
blah blah they were the ones that got in
trouble
uh i think it was on twitter because i
forgot which
what which article or what they had
posted but twitter was like this is
misinformation you have to delete this
or you don't get access to your account
or you can't post rather and then people
like uh
matt gates and ted cruz are like ah this
is against the first amendment right you
know [ __ ] we're being cancelled
there's consequences whatever you want
but you're on someone's private platform
right you have to agree to certain terms
of service oh there's such things as
terms of service yeah well that's what
that's come on
come on
if there were no terms of service yeah
or anyone moderating twitter would be
essentially 4chan
right well i mean in some respects and
some signs of twitter it appears that
way yeah but when they actually get
moderated it they they get crushed
because of the i don't know what's the
uh the terms of service
yeah
you know it's it's funny how i got i got
my freedom to say whatever i want which
you do
you do
whatever you want you can type in
anything you want on twitter
and push tweet
and then they can get rid of it because
it's their platform you can tweet
whatever you want but the consequence
may be
that you just lose your account or you
can't tweet you know that that that kind
of but you're saying
this interview is joe rogan interviewing
the owner
and they were talking about abortion and
the topic of someone who is who is a
teenager
comes up and whether it is right or
wrong and joe rogan steps in and uh you
know i didn't i honestly wasn't
expecting him to
well here did you just watch let's watch
you don't have a right to tell my 14
year old daughter she has to carry her
rapist baby you understand look that
woman in the eye who's who was there
you understand that that's a 14 year old
child if you a 14 year old child gets
raped you say that they have to carry
that baby i don't think two wrongs make
it right i don't think i don't think
murder is an answer to three days
what if she just turned positive just
now positive for pregnancy i don't i
well i just disagree that what if it
just happened you can like draw a line
on when you can't once again so you
can't at the very moment
so joe rogan they're basically saying
hey [ __ ] you are not gonna get a
your religion is not gonna get all up in
my daughter's body right exactly it
really is it really is um something else
to watch as again this consequence thing
comes around and the consequence of
perpetuating the [ __ ] that you
perpetuate comes back to bite you in the
ass when you when you lift up and you
prop up these [ __ ] idiots
in your platform to millions and
millions of people brainwash these
people into believing that this ideology
is something that they should follow and
they should hail and that they should
they should emulate and then when when
it turns around on you
and they actually do you're like oh quit
getting hysterical quit getting
hysterical they're not gonna make it to
where 14 year old girls are forced to
have babies yeah they are yeah they did
and they're wanting to go further yeah
and oh and sorry i'm sorry i i misspoke
not the founder uh that's adam ford he's
the
the the guy who just spoke was um
was seth dillon okay he's the owner and
in the ceo
so okay so so he's not the founder he
just bought it
but he just runs it he is the one that
is running and making you know making
these things right uh but it is one of
those situations where yeah you've got
this you know conservative right-wing
religious christian
uh you know satirical site right
and
keeping aside the whole like you know
satire is the guy's personal opinion is
that
wherever whenever it happens it's
illegal abortion is illegal no matter
what happens right he's okay with he's
okay with the scenario that joe rogan's
laying out that you should force a 14
year old girl right
to force her to have birth they're
forced birthers they are important and
so joe rogan's like cool okay well
here's my experience here i have a 14
year old daughter and the fact that you
are telling me that she has to have a
baby if she gets raped no [ __ ] that what
you think is the
response of any
father any parent if their daughter is
raped and for whatever reason state law
you know court whatever says you have to
have this baby i think anyone in their
right mind that isn't a part of a
religious cult like christianity
would say nope not happening we are not
happening that child is not mature
enough they are not old enough they
cannot support themselves financially we
cannot do this right i mean you look at
florida who says oh yeah 16 year old
daughter or a girl
she's not mature enough to make the
choice right but she's mature enough to
have a kid which you have to talk about
the physical
and both uh both physical and emotional
and mental
anguish and and and stress that puts on
someone especially someone who is a
developing
young adult
to put that on them and say hey good
luck trying to recover from this years
down the line well i want to point
something out here joe rogan actually he
lived in california he moved to texas
so joe rogan
literally packed his family up moved to
texas and now lives in the state where
he with his with his children right
where this would happen to his 14 year
old girl yeah if they didn't well and
joe rogan and this is this is why this
is why just pointing this out because
joe rogan could pack his [ __ ] back and
move back to california yeah and live in
a state but a lot of people in texas
can't do that they can't do that and joe
rogan be so irresponsible of having
these dumb [ __ ] these people
who don't know what they're talking
about this ivermectin [ __ ] this trump
delusion [ __ ] all this [ __ ] that he did
during and after the pandemic to
perpetuate trumpism in this country to
an audience which he knew was primed to
perpetuate this garbage yeah
to do that is irresponsible and really
honestly him being mad about what he's
being mad at he has the right to be mad
about that he has the right to be
passionate about his daughter yeah but
in the same respect joe rogan
you have perpetuated what you're mad
about you have done this you have helped
give these people platforms to do this
[ __ ] yeah to make this to make this
somehow a a normal thing that we
consider that teenage girls are forced
to give birth to babies that possibly
come from rape and incest you piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ] so i'm glad joe rogan is
finally trying to see the light and i
hope he does more and more of this and i
hope when he's when he invites these
pieces of [ __ ] on his show he goes after
him like he did here because that's what
he should have been doing the entire
[ __ ] time he was having these vile
pieces of [ __ ] on his show that's what
he should have been doing the entire
time and showing his audience that
liberalism is the tough thing to do
right it is easy to lay down and let
someone take your rights away to stand
up and fight for your rights and fight
for your 14 year old daughter's rights
that is the thing that is tough that's
the thing that shows strength not
weakness so you can kiss my ass when you
say liberals are weak um i want to go
real quick i don't mean to switch gears
but i want to check in on the poll here
whoa
um
looking banned here it's looking bad
here um on the poll of should should at
tony michaels d tony michaels do the
entire episode
with an alex jones voice now the the i
was thinking about this the real way if
i wanted to screw it would be right
should tony michaels not
do an entire episode with an alex jones
voice and then put you know no yes not
sure
and then see people catch the knot
that's it right right um
maybe we should do another poll later on
see how many people catch it
but here the consensus is that it is not
a thing that they want me to do for the
entire episode yeah yeah so again you
could do it
for five minutes 50 minutes
one hour 55 minutes
[Laughter]
or just when i bring up alex jones lips
and totally mock him and make fun of him
i i still think that we should um have
some kind of um a cabal toothpaste
though that is a thing oh yeah yeah we
should definitely get some cabal
toothpaste on the merch store speaking
of the merch store if you want to go uh
see the merch store we don't have
toothpaste on there yet we're planning
on it apparently now go to
thetonymichaels.com you can find the
merch stores there and you can find
gabe's as well you can also find the
support supportlinksupport.tonymichaelspod.com
and also the qr code is in the corner
thanks to the graphics department the
graphics department did a great job with
yeah
graphics over there if you want to
support the show if you want to support
pro democracy speech today go to the
link um take a picture of the qr code
that's how that works apparently yeah i
know can you can you screenshot a qr
code does the audience know this can you
screenshot it and then go i don't know i
don't know i don't think so if you're on
your cell phone because you can't take a
picture right when you're on your cell
phone i don't know how that works i
don't know i've never tried to do it
before i could do moderators moderators
were that were um mj specifically was
asking for the qr code
right but i didn't know if you could
screenshot it or if you can i don't know
i have no idea i don't know i'm not i've
never i've never tried to
to take a screenshot and then scan it
before i mean like anna can you do that
i know i mean
look if i take it i'm on the i'm on the
show right now on my phone i'm going to
take a oh no turn this on cmj says you
scan it from the pc but what yeah what
happens when they're watching no but
yeah but that but that's what we're
saying like what you have to take the
photo but then you have something else
to scan the photo if you're watching
from your computer then it works but if
you're watching on your phone i don't
know how it doesn't work
we're actually doing we're putting up
technology here that we don't fully
understand folks i mean
man we are getting aged out of the
internet i know okay boomer okay
i had a conversation there's got to be a
way to do it i was reading an article
that was talking about the i don't know
if anyone's heard about the millennial
pause
but it's this moment before you record
where you don't do anything to make sure
that it's recording
and it's called this millennial it's a
thing that's being discussed right now
which is like oh you can identify
someone who's a millennial because they
ask
or they do certain mannerisms one of
which is this millennial pause before
they start recording a video that goes
online to make sure that it's recording
but for me i'm like that's not wait i
don't think wait wait wait wait wait
you're saying what you're saying at that
gym days all right so like yesterday
hold please
i got my i got my phone right and i i
press record and i wait a moment
before i start speaking like like a half
a second yeah like a half second to be
like cool recording or like a second
into it then i'm like hey everyone you
know and then i go people and at the end
of the videos you see people hitting the
right right i'm not one of those people
it's like let's cut it off but also but
here's the thing
my experience has never been like oh i
gotta make sure it's recording
because i'm a millennial or whatever the
reason is because i come from a film
background so i'm like all right cool oh
yes filmmaker here well i'm just saying
for the editing process you're like all
right great i'm going to record and i
want to give a few seconds of time and
then we can start and say action right
we can just deliver the lines or
whatever it might be
but
it's this whole concept it's it's
fascinating i think it's wrong in some
ways but that's just me
i see i see well
either way either way rather you pause
or you don't pause um i think you should
just smash the record button and start
talking before that way oh yeah just
like cut it in it's raw it's authentic
right you know that's how you know it's
real that's that's how it's real raw
yeah loud and proud
like the intro says so so do whatever
you can to get the qr code regardless of
your phones i just got a text message uh
president trump
yeah oh boy five thousand breaking news
no no no this is just a text message
five thousand percent more as my top
supporter
that's me i've never donated though i've
texted you five thousand percent more
than anyone else
want to stay number one
claim here and then you click the link
and you go and do that and don't add but
that's
it's a text message that came from trump
and he goes five i've texted you
5 000
more
than anyone else which is so untrue
because i recently signed up for these
text messages and i've never donated
once
to this [ __ ] well i'll tell you
you should not donate to trump if you
want to donate you should you should
support pro-democracy speech as mj but
i'm also like
can you i'm i'm curious like if you can
if you if you can sue for some of this
stuff like the way that he's
well i don't know is it false marketing
because technically it's just but here's
the thing here's the thing he did he did
create one of the biggest frauds on
american history yeah he's setting a lot
of records he is winning
bigly in a lot of these categories right
fraud
espionage he is a lot of winning a lot
of winning he might he possibly might go
go down yeah he the most corrupt
president ever in the history i mean at
the end of the day he could also go down
because of weisselberg in the same way
that al capone went down and all the
other things are just like irrelevant
now i mean how much would we do going to
do he's going to do a ton of winning
here
oh the former guy the former guy
i can't believe we still the last two
weeks it's again it's been like not
every day has been something new whether
it's been news about the the search it's
been his taxes it's been about this tax
fraud
all the every day he he he uh puts out a
post on truth social or says something
it is immediately refuted and debunked
well and they continue to change their
story right yeah right like like it's
continuing to change
um and it's just it's nonsense i can't
keep track and that's why i'm doing what
was that which is going to be tracking
in the last two weeks or so
uh the
amount of lies
or the amount of excuses that he's gone
from they stole it it was mine i
declassified it i was gonna declassify
it uh you know this i took them as
mementos and i was scrapbooking
uh you know all of those things where
it's like oh uh they went into the
closet did they go into the closet what
did they steal from the closet you know
and it's like they didn't steal anything
it was a legal search warrant you know
unwarranted unprecedented
unprecedented yeah unprecedented
unprecedented
who who uh who who said who said um who
typed it out that way was it lauren
bobert that typed it out that way or is
it martin i don't know i mean i probably
say it that way every once in a while
because you know i get guy
right so yeah i know i know well at
least you're not like i mean lauren
beaubert said immeachment
uh uh what was it and and what was it
immeachment what does that mean what
does that mean impeach
oh
oh that's when she was like
each tree dish
yeah exactly so and well here's what
happened she sent out a newsletter uh
a few months ago
and lauren bobert was like oh it's time
to imitch joe biden ymich
and everyone's like what the [ __ ] is the
meat it is it is time to meet you and
then margaret taylor green's like oh
yeah you know
peat tree
dish no peach peach right yeah it's a
peach sorry i want to say it correctly
i want to say correctly because i'm not
a [ __ ] dumbass and and what you do
you put salsa in the peach tree dish
and you dip your your immeachment chips
in the in the sausage
and they're served by the gazpacho
police they it is it is they are it that
well that's who's at the restaurant
right the pizza the pizza
restaurant that has the kids yeah which
is owned by jack prosthesis right right
yeah who also who also who also knows
for sure the person who um operates this
jewish space lasers right right she sets
all the forest fires to convince
everyone as a false flag that there is
um climate change now here's the thing
everyone sure every everyone here is
is like is this true is this not true i
don't know uh we're making a joke right
now but these are in fact everything
that they may believe that they have
said whether it's lauren bobert talking
about immeachment right uh it's marger
taylor green saying peach tree space
lasers right you got uh you know dr oz
not knowing what a veggie dish is none
of this stuff is made up we just happen
to make a joke about it right now but
these are literal things that they said
well there's a lot of things that people
say apparently ben stein is um
is trending oh god he's on truth social
really yeah it's a question
um of course he is of course this
[ __ ] idiot i have honestly i haven't
heard of ben stein since his show on
comedy central years ago he goes on fox
he's like a contributor on there
um because he can't right probably get
uh he's an economist right yeah
okay uh ben stein he
he he
truth here i hate that that's so stupid
why did they do that why why
well yeah but it's it sounds stupid like
i mean i mean right like what do you
expect come on these are the people that
do not have a funny bone in their body
they do not look they look at a design
like twitter and they say i want that
and then they mimic the design yeah
where it's literally laid out better
same way word than truth
truth is not it's i mean twitter they're
trying to make it to into a verb because
you don't say you twitter you say tweet
when you look at the design between uh
truth social and twitter it is almost
identical copy right is it kind of well
they don't use a block check mark they
use a pink check
but there's a lot of there's a lot of
functionality that that
true social doesn't have
like you can't there's a lot of things
like i ca i try to set a notification
for him
and i can't find where you set up the
notification because i gotta go over and
manually check whenever i think whenever
i get a really dumb thought this is what
happens whenever i get a really dumb
thought in my head i'm like oh that's
really stupid i'm like i need to go
check true social like that's literally
when i check it
is when i get when i think when i
literally think this is the dumbest
thing i've ever heard i'm like oh let's
go see what grandpa poopypants is
posting on true social surely it's
dumber over there yeah but here here is
something really [ __ ] stupid
um again on truesocial that ben stein
posted he says we have a media that is
working night and day to demolish the
idea of trumpism good great all right
you're right and trumpism is beat listen
to this basic trumpism here's what he's
claiming trump trumpism is basically
old-fashioned republicanism no
he's gay oh it gets better it's going to
get better
tony that original g.o.p no
what started a [ __ ] argument to free
the slaves okay so what he's arguing is
that all of the republi which he this i
can't even believe that anyone listens
to anything this guy says when he says
this sentence the original gop was
started to free the slaves that's not
even close
not even close he clearly doesn't even
understand that part of the republican
party
during that time during the civil war
wanted slavery like he clearly does not
understand this that
that is what the republican party was
founded on nope sorry not a thing yeah
but also he doesn't he doesn't
acknowledge the fact that the gop back
then was basically the democrats right
like the way that they flipped
right but but again you have to
understand back then the the separation
of parties was federalism and
anti-federalism it wasn't liberal and
conservative there was liberals and
conservatives that were in each party
but the divide was between really was
between federalism and i mean there's a
lot of other divides but that was that's
why that's why they still claim oh
because here's what they say this same
[ __ ] who say oh yeah the gop
was started to free the slaves but
slavery
it was about that that that war was not
about slavery it was about states rights
like the same [ __ ] and those are two
opposite things like here he continues
he continues here gabe he says now the
democrat party
has never done anything like this in
history oh yeah like not like i don't
know um civil rights
why does the republican party not get
credit for that
what get credit for what why does does
he put two dozes there uh the republican
party not gather its nuts together
what
and say we are the party of the
greatness of america because you're not
yeah okay i see what he's saying the
last line gathered her nuts is like
gathering like right like a squirrel
yeah well yeah like they're gathering
all of their like accomplishments
they're like you know like oh this is
what we've done oh they grabble they
they get they love to grab nuts
they love the grab nuts and they love to
gather up their lunatics their jobs they
love the gathering you think you're nuts
but now i see you crazy you're crazy
[ __ ] uh yeah that's it oh god when
people try to when people try to use
that argument like one
we are the party of lincoln and i i did
a tweet the other day when we're like oh
gop is like we're the party of lincoln
you know and then abraham lincoln's like
the [ __ ] you are
[Laughter]
that is that is exactly how he that did
exactly they are not the party of
lincoln lincoln like you know had his
faults he wasn't awesome and great you
know so here's the thing if if you
really go back and look at that look at
um during that time the 13th 14th
amendment in the civil war and you look
at what lincoln was trying to do the
people in the republican party today
would be the ones pushing back on him in
his own party yeah um that's that's who
would be pushing back on him it wouldn't
i mean it would be democrats too
who were of the same who were of the
same conservative mindset because again
there were what they referred to as
radicals which were the liberals
nowadays and then the conservatives who
wanted to conserve what they had right
like that was the whole purpose is we do
not want to change we want to keep the
status quo which was
uh slavery
so
they they really are they really are
mentally challenged and ben stein really
needs to have his [ __ ]
his head checked he must have head up
ass syndrome any cranial dysfunction
because he clearly needs to pluck his
head out of his ass as do many
many trump supporters in this country
and if you want to participate
in in
helping this country
with their annual aniocranial syndrome
this dysfunction they have this head up
ass syndrome
come here every single day we will we
will show you the way we will show you
how to teach these people to pluck their
head out of their ass two hours every
single weekday here on the tony michaels
podcast monday through friday noon
eastern 11 central nine pacific on
youtube twitter and twitch and
simulcasting from the minus touch
facebook page don't forget to subscribe
to the youtube channel don't miss a
thing you can go watch don't forget to
go to the satire and parody playlist go
watch the fbi unboxing video again and
again it's a great video a great video
also follow at tony michael's pod don't
forget to vote in the alex jones poll
but also the bonehead of the week poll
it's going to come out
i mean you know practicing democracy wow
voting voting well benjamin seems like
he could be a contender on that thing
i'm just saying also download every
single episode seven days a week on
apple spotify google your favorite
directory leave a
great great fantastic
fantastic review there it would be
fantastic it would be bigly nice of you
to leave a review so go
download each and every episode leave a
great review on your favorite directory
don't forget tomorrow is friday
and friday in the second hour we do
bonehead of the week don't forget to
vote for bonehead of the week you can
vote here on youtube and on twitter
support pro democracy speech today go to
support.tonymichaelspod.com
or do whatever you do with the qr code
down in the corner whether you take a
screenshot or you take a picture
whatever the hell you do with the thing
until tomorrow surfs up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born had asked